kaylee
is with us kaylee is in colorado springs
hi kaley how are you
hi dave i'm great how are you better
than i deserve how can rachel anna help
uh thank you for taking my call so i'm
calling because my husband and i
uh just sold our home and we're about to
finish baby step two with the profits
from that
all right and we will have seven
thousand dollars
left over after we pay our debt off
great
we wanted to um instead of
directly going into baby step three um
his mom had helped us quite a bit when
he was newly enlisted in the army
and not making a lot of money yet so we
wanted to give her
uh five thousand dollars because she's
out of work right now with kovid
and um struggling a little bit my
question is when we called her to let
her know
we were going to send that um instead of
she had always given us money as a gift
and said she didn't want to ever be paid
back
and when we told her we were going to
send her 5 000
uh she kind of acted like oh that's all
so now we're kind of worried about
straining that relationship with her
and we're wondering if we should send
her more
and not pay off all of our debt right
now
and kind of work on it the rest of this
year
or um if we should
pay off all of our debt still and maybe
give her more money
later down the road kelly did you is
this an assumption that that's how
she felt from her tone or did she say
with her words did you guys ask
questions and have a more in-depth
conversation so you know exactly
what she's thinking um
so we we tried to she kind of
just said well i'm you know i'm so happy
for you guys i want you to be out of
debt but
um you know she has a lot of debt
herself
and she's just she's having a really
hard time
um we also know though she even though
she's out of work
she is single she lives for free with
her sister who's a retired nurse
so she's got a roof over her head she
has food to eat she just
makes a lot of poor decisions with the
money that she does make
so we don't want to we want to be
generous we don't want to
keep we don't want to enable that
because we don't
agree with the choices that she makes
but um
yeah we're just we don't want to we
don't want to strain the relationship
we don't want to well you know she said
that's fine give me 5 000 and you know
pay off your debt and we'll worry about
me later
and that's what she said never
yeah we're worried that's going to be a
never-ending thing
yeah and we don't want to be supporting
her
her bad decisions here yeah well i think
that there's
levels of communication that have to be
had and there's going to be boundaries
that you guys are going to set and so
to be un as as dave ramsey sitting next
to me would always say in life
to be unclear is to be unkind and so
from the story you've told me she has
given you guys money in the past to help
you but she said i never want it repaid
now you guys are in a better situation
financially you're getting your debt
paid off you have some extra cash and
you think okay
we're going to bless her and give her a
gift to help her during this hard time
partly because yeah she helped us in the
past but this is our gift to her no
strings attached
so what you have to realize is that if
there is a gift that you guys feel like
you want to give her
there has to be no strings attached
you're going to know that she's probably
going to mismanage this money
and if you give her more that's the more
she's going to mismanage that money
and so if there's a if there's an amount
that you guys want to give and say hey
you know again because of the situation
you're in we're choosing to give you
this
but mom here's the plan we as a couple
are getting out of debt we're going
through the baby steps and once we get
out of it and if you
would like to come along this journey
with us and you want to go through
ramsay plus and you want to take some
online classes and
budget and you start doing these things
we'd love to walk beside you
but we want this money to be a blessing
to you and not a curse
yeah so here's the deal if you give her
5 000
or you give her 15 000 it doesn't change
a thing
does it yummy
so you can't give her enough money
because you don't have enough money
for her problems to go away
right so give her five thousand dollars
and tell her let your husband handle
this this is his mom you can't handle it
you are the daughter-in-law
which means when you talk it doesn't go
well
so you need to be real quiet he needs to
handle this with his mom very very
slow cadence of speech
deep octave
which indicates that he's feeling very
calm
and very strong mom
i love you and we are so excited that
we're getting out of debt we're gonna
give you this five thousand dollars
when you gave us the other money you
said it was a gift with no strings and
we're giving you this money
as a gift with no strings we're not
going to be able to do this very often
or maybe never again and we would like
to help you in other ways and t
let you go along with us on this journey
that we're going on
you may or may not want to do that but
if you wanted to go through financial
peace
and ramsay plus mom will pay for it for
you as a part of
and we'll add that to the five thousand
dollars but mom i'm not repaying
everything you gave me because when you
gave it to me you told me it was a gift
and let yourself be free of her little
guilt trip that she laid
cut the cut the tie on that clean
otherwise she's going to keep coming
back to the well and she's going to feel
entitled to come back to the well
because you didn't cut
he didn't cut the apron strings so he
she is she the only reason she's
misbehaving here
is because she's scared and she's broke
if this woman had money she actually is
silly generous
because she gave you money probably she
didn't have back then
right exactly yeah yeah so she's not a
bad person that breaks her promises
she's just a scared person
and i really am going to have to let her
fear that is leading her to shame
me lay over there in her house not in my
house
that's the boundary that sounds very
mean or very tough
but there's not enough money to stop
this from happening and there is no end
to this
thread if you pull it on this sweater am
i right kaylee
yes that's right that's what we're
worried about he
has to handle this not you
you don't even need to be on the phone
okay because you're gonna end up being
the wicked witch of the west in this
story if you are and i don't want you to
get that reputation in this situation
i want you to be free of it matter of
fact if she's mad at somebody i'd rather
her be mad at her son
than her daughter-in-law because that's
harder for her to do
this is not a bad person she's scared
and she's out of control
and if you can help her not be and if
you can help her get in control like
rachel said and not be scared
that's going to be worth 50 000 to her
not five thousand but you you really
can't you don't have any money
you don't have enough money to change
this woman's life
now later on if you've got a million
dollars and you want to give her a
hundred thousand and straighten her life
up
you can change her life doing that she
still go back and screw it up but
you can change your life but right now
you don't have
the difference in what you can do that
strains you
versus the 5000 is not a difference
maker in this story it doesn't change
the story
so i'd stick with the five and i'd lay
down a boundary clip the apron strings
and offered a cheerleading help and walk
through
ramsey plus financial peace university
together with her
that's what i would do if i were in your
shoes
these are some of the most difficult
conversations that people
ever have around money i think this kind
of conversation is even harder than a
marital conversation
because of the relationship between a
parent and a child and it's
you're taking care of the parents like
role reversal feeling well and
just the dynamic of it i mean i diapered
you you owe me
yeah yeah i bought you school clothes i
worked three extra jobs
when you were 12 years old and you owe
me
no that was kind of your job
[Laughter]
no it's not how this works but there is
something
a child is not enslaved to you forever
based on your freaking misbehavior no
but it may be the next break we'll talk
about after the break but but how to
honor your parents
yeah well you can't do that but it's
just the assumption of somebody's guilt
tripping
totally totally all right going into
that break we're talking about
moms or dads asking for money or asking
for help
yeah and i just think it's an
interesting discussion because there's a
level
of unhealthiness that a parent can have
to say oh yeah i'm entitled
to some of your money as a child and
expect their
adult children to help them but there
also
is the beauty in in helping your parents
if you've worked this plan and you're
out of debt you have an emergency fund
and you're building wealth
and so we're talking about like what's
the balance of not enabling bad behavior
if they choose to to do poor things with
money
but yet being able to bless and help
your parents well and you can add to the
conversation those of us that are
christians we see clearly in the bible
honor
honor of your father and mother yep as
people that are listening
listeners out there you know of how to
direct them and doing that well if
that's something that they choose to do
okay so it's a little bit like
um honoring the president
okay if you do that you may very well
disagree with
the person that's in office their
politics their procedures their
theology their beliefs their values
whatever
but you still honor the office of the
president
um and you pray for the president even
if you disagree with them
dramatically you know uh we've lost a
lot of that in our country and we've
lost this other thing so you can honor
the office
of fatherhood or motherhood without
honoring misbehavior
so an extreme example your your dad is
doing cocaine
and he keeps asking you for money well
unless you're completely screwed in the
head you are you know you're released
from the obligation to give a cocaine
addict money
i mean right right so now how do you how
do you honor
father that's a cocaine addict i mean
how do you do that well you have to
honor
the fact that he's dad the father but
you don't honor the cocaine part
and you don't participate in that part
by funding it
right right you know and so a much more
minor example someone who's just
like that last lady is misbehaving with
money she makes bad money decisions her
daughter-in-law said
and she has throughout her whole life
and she lives in her
sister's house because she didn't have a
place to live because she's not even
taking care of her money enough to
maintain the dignity of that and it's
all because of choices according to the
story we heard
right right so we can honor mom we can
honor her generosity towards this couple
early in their marriage when he's first
in the military and that as she said
but we don't have to honor her situation
uh we don't have to honor her behavior
we can just honor her
and love her right where she is and so
you can
it's a little bit of love the sinner
hate the sin
kind of a thing and so that allows you
to be kind
but it also allows you to separate the
behavior and not
become an enabler and giving someone
money
that is not helping if it's not helping
right you're an enabler that's what it
comes down to
and you're falling for guilt trips and
you've got a toxic environment
and well you know i'm afraid i won't
have a relationship
with them if you have to pay for a
relationship that's called prostitution
that's not
it's not a real relationship it's not i
mean if you have to have paid for
friends you don't have real friends and
so
if you have a if the only way your mom
talks to you is you give her money
this relationship was gone a long time
ago it's time to call it
and so um you are not
morally spiritually obligated
to give anyone money
anyone except minor children that are
yours
you're morally obligated spiritually
obligated to take care of children
your own especially but you are not
obligated to take care of your sibling
you're not obligated to take care of
your uncle
your grandmother your mother your grown
child who continually misbehaves since
31 and living in your basement
you're not morally or spiritually
obligated now we
love them even the stupid ones
and you know we do and we we can honor
the fact that this is my brother my
sister this is my mother this is
whatever right
you can honor that but you don't have to
honor the stupidity
and you don't have to fund it to prove
that you love them or to give them honor
giving honor is separate from giving
them money
they're two different things and it's
very difficult to separate especially
when someone is a travel agent for guilt
trips and they just call you up and go
well i did this for you and now you
leave me out oh yeah
you feel terrible yeah you know i'm
afraid if i don't give my daughter money
that
that my grandbabies won't have any money
to eat any food to eat
because that's what she tells me you
know like the mother that calls up just
calls her mother and says mom i need
some money if you don't feed if you
don't give me some money your
grandbabies aren't gonna eat well that's
just
you know that's just low blow right
there so
uh because they feel entitled i talk to
people on an inheritance issue that they
feel entitled
to their parents money upon their death
it's not yours
yeah you don't have an entitlement to it
you don't have a right to it
leaving an inheritance is a choice of
the person who owns the money
not the person receiving it and so you
know this concept that somehow
that uh you you hit the dna lottery by
being in someone's family
uh is uh is false
and so but then the problem is as you
navigate it
it's always a very rough conversation
because you can never give enough and
when you finally realize that
then you also find out that um
that this whole thing was ragged out
anyway and it wasn't going to work yeah
and then the relationship goes sideways
and so um
you can give somebody money for 10 years
and then stop and they'll not speak to
you
you know because they've become entitled
it's a short-term band-aid
yeah over some bigger issues eventually
eventually this runs out you know
eventually somebody runs out of money
somewhere
or patience or something and and so that
that's what
you know you know dr henry cloud's book
the boundaries
is um
[Music]
uh is the bible for this for this
discussion
and being able to set boundaries in
place now the truth is
that our family my family and sharon's
family
have not been an issue
they've been happy for us that we've
become successful financially and
they don't all line up the door wanting
money matter of fact none of them have
ever asked us for a dime
ever that's pretty weird honestly uh but
it's a blessing
yeah so we you know we're not discussing
like i have a friend
it's really me we're not doing that you
know this is this is and you know our
kids are self-sufficient you guys don't
come to us for money um and we don't
certainly don't come to you for money
and that kind of stuff so
it's um but if somebody in
if one of your cousins needed help on
something their kid was
had a medical thing or whatever we would
be there in heartbeat
but there would not but they're not the
type of people that would lay that out
as an
expectation that we would be there it
would be a
it's not generosity if you're shamed
into it
what you're talking about the spirit of
it yeah oh yeah absolutely because i
think
or at least i've my i have friends and
we've talked about okay so how do we
honor our parents
if kids have become more successful than
their parents financially what does that
look like and so having that discussion
um is just fascinating it's very
interesting so most of the parents don't
care
yeah like i know a situation like that
that is a good friend of both of ours
and he paid his dad's house off the
other day just to watch his dad cry he
wanted to see his dad cry
it was fabulous it was just an act of
generosity though and dad had in no way
inferred
that he was due that yep it's good